she lies four thousand meters under the
Atlantic Ocean an enduring attraction
researchers and tourists pay good money
to go underwater to view the Titanic
this is the small vessel that took the
trip with five people on board and
hasn't come back
called the Titan it's operated by The
Firm Ocean Gate expeditions a ticket to
the Titanic cost two hundred thousand
pounds ahead
the vessel is transported to the site of
the wreck by the polar Prince Tugboat
currently eight sets a few hundred
meters from the location
it's understood that among the five on
borders Paul on renogly a French
submersible pilot so too is British man
Hamish Harding this is his Instagram
post from last week in which he said a
weather window had opened up and they
were going to attempt a dive
a Twitter post from Sunday spoke of a
successful launch after a 4 AM start
with them is believed to be stocked in
Rush the founder of the company involved
he spoke to Sky News earlier this year
that's what I love about shipwrecks they
are artificial reefs and they get
populated quite quickly I think most
people are surprised by it but it is
it's just it's an amazing thing that
happens and the hundreds have shipped
thousands of ships from World War one
and World War II of similar construction
are at the bottom of the ocean and
they're creating these amazing man-made
reefs and so it's just incredible the
Titanic shipwreck sits nearly two and a
half miles down at the bottom of the
Atlantic Ocean
it's around 400 miles off the coast of
Newfoundland in Canada
a multinational search and rescue
operation is no underway
Coast Guard aircraft from Halifax and
North Carolina are assisting in the
joint effort contact was lost with the
vessel an hour and 45 minutes into its
dive emergency systems can sustain
people on board for 96 hours the Coast
Guard spoke of a Race Against Time in
terms of the hours we understood that
that was 96 hours of rescue or emergency
capability from from the operator and so
we anticipate that there's somewhere
between uh 70 to the full 96 hours
available at this point in a statement
the company involved Ocean Gate
Expedition said our entire focus is on
the crew members in the submersible and
their families we are deeply thankful
for the extensive assistance we've
received from several government
agencies and deep sea companies in our
efforts to re-establish contact with the
submersible
typically there will be equipment on
board the vessel including oxygen to Aid
survival for a limited period but as
time elapses so does Hope
James Matthews Sky News in Washington